[Música]
están todos buenas buenas buenas
está echando vocales
y jaibas estoy feliz de estar aquí en
tamaulipas y estar con ustedes en este
mi primer terex y ojalá que sea el
primero de muchos
yo título mi plática con ustedes el día
de hoy
por algo muy importante que se llama
vencer el miedo
y es que creo creo que para todos los
rubros de la vida no solamente para
quien se dedica a mi profesión que es la
música y la creatividad pues hay que
vencer el miedo y
comenzaría por decirles que he vivido el
año más el 2018 fue para mí el año más
controvertido y complejo no de repente
en 30 años de carrera nunca había dado
de qué hablar y de pronto en un año de
todo de kevlar desde que le dije adela
micha que no me gustaba el reggaeton en
todo mundo se vino encima de mí y en la
calle pues voy caminando y me dicen que
está contigo que muera el reggaeton y
luego pasa otro 4 y se pincha el existe
vas a ver way te pasaste con mis
carnales del reggaeton win y así me la
paso no así que digo ay por un
comentario así es esta profesión no esté
desgraciadamente a veces estamos en una
época en la que las etiquetas son muy
fuertes muy fuertes y si sin querer
queriendo le pegaste un perro ya eres el
mataperros
entonces
tienes que estar te cuidando mucho no y
eso da mucho miedo fue muy difícil para
la gente que como yo empezamos desde muy
chicos en este medio de entretenimiento
vivir el cambio a las redes sociales ya
estar en contacto directo con mucha
gente
porque hay gente que te quiere y hay
gente que te quiere pero de una manera
salvaje y que les importas pero de una
manera medio violenta y brusca no es
ahorita lo platicaba con tatiana es muy
difícil
hacer de tripas corazón y decir no no yo
soy de palo tengo orejas de pescado es
muy difícil y más cuando eres muy
emocional y cuando te importa mucho
servir a los demás porque yo creo que
esa es la base más importante de obtener
el éxito escuché por ejemplo jardín
dupeyrón que decía que lo importante no
era ser exitoso sino trascender y estoy
muy muy de acuerdo con él
porque pienso que
la trascendencia tiene que ver más
con servir a los demás pero os resulta
muy difícil también estar como expuesto
y estar vulnerable
en mis épocas constaba chavitos los
artistas y los famosos eran como
viviendo una burbuja eran como
inalcanzables hoy están más a la mano
están allí la luz es el aleks syntek más
un saab el edificio y entonces éste
es complicado porque no estábamos
acostumbrados eso hace 10 años
me invitaron a hacer una canción para el
bicentenario de méxico uso orales que
padre y me habló en el secretario de
educación pública y me dijo señor siento
que queremos que haga sí señor sanz la
neta la neta no le iba a decir nada
háblale a probéis y yo paso pues no
y desgraciadamente cuando te metes en
algo que tiene que ver con lo político
pues no te lo acabas y
yo torpe que no sé usar estas nuevas
herramientas cuando vi todas las
críticas tu rol es una porquería y tú
vales madres me quedé así de que
hago que hoy y en ese momento pensé que
mostrarme vulnerable era lo ideal no
esté decirle a la gente oigan lo hice
con mucho amor por méxico y por mí y
traté de dar lo mejor de mí y pues a lo
mejor no será mi mejor canción pero es
lo que me pidieron y eso es lo que hago
y no tienen derecho a de hablarme así no
se defendió el güey darle con todo acá
un y papás empezaron así para pa pa pa a
llover me de críticas horribles no
no sé si alguna vez estuvieron en la
escuela a mí se me pasó en la primaria y
entonces de repente a alguien no se te
ocurría un chiste o alguna broma para el
profesor para los compañeros de la
escuela y se quedaba todo el salón
callado y tú decías que podemos ser que
el profesor longaniza no y todos desean
así el salón de clase y madre escalón y
era trágate la vergüenza porque acabas
de pasar un ridículo
total no ahora imagínense
tres millones de personas en un en una
red social no viendo al personaje está
cañón fue fue muy fuerte no pero mi
abuelo decía que lo que no te mata te
hace más grande siempre creí que mostrar
mis defectos de carácter mostrarme mi
lado humano éste era ser vulnerable y
que y que ser ridiculizado también
podría ser lo peor que me podría pasar
lo que podría ser este el fin no de mi
persona y de mi carrera además no porque
a lo mejor mucha gente dice no no no no
es que como aleks syntek e bárbaro güey
como una fiesta no ya no va a
comprar tus discos ni voy a oír tus
canciones porque eres muy no no
no
pues no no es así eso medio dice mi
cabeza eso me lo dice mi mente
y también pienso que mi mente me miente
yo estoy aquí el día de hoy pudiendo
agradecerle a la vida el ser una persona
que ha podido satisfacer sus metas y sus
deseos profesionales
porque seguimos siempre seguido mis
corazonadas entonces mi mensaje
principal es que hay que seguir tu
corazón y no hacerle mucho caso a la
mente y muchas veces detrás de esos
miedos por ahí hay una plática de will
smith que estoy muy de acuerdo
detrás de los de los grandes miedos
están muchas de las satisfacciones más
grandes de la vida
y hoy día este año ha sido bien difícil
porque
cualquier cosa cualquier tropezón que yo
hacía en las redes sociales era es
clasista es racista es homofóbico es
acosador y un zawiya jacques por favor
que alguno sea lo único que estoy
diciendo es este
quiero ser aceptado y querido pero entre
más quiero ser aceptado y querido más me
odian o más me tiran
y fue bien difícil porque sobre todo el
ego se defiende y yo me defiendo y digo
no a animales les voy a dar una lección
hasta que dices
a ver way y tú porque te quiere la gente
por tus grandes decisiones o tus grandes
comentarios al final no soy ni orador
yo soy yo soy cantante yo me dedico a
hacer canciones y a tocar el piano no
esté bueno 20 como que me cayó el veinte
y dije no eres de impacto para que acá
no estés paolo coelho eres aleks syntek
y lo tuyo es cantar les duele el amor tú
necesitas y este y de vez en cuando
cantar bailar el mundo que en el
escenario este que sorprende mucho
porque no no saben que se hace el mundo
que así
en honor al gran michael entonces este
y me he dado cuenta una vez más
yo tengo miedo como todos empieza a
temblar y corro igual que todo el mundo
no no digo yo soy a la gente que a mi no
me va a pasar nada me caí encima no esté
pero si me he dado cuenta que enfrentar
esos miedos ha sido lo más importante en
mi vida y que los triunfos realmente no
no son tan importantes sino cuántas
veces te levantes del suelo las veces
que te caigas te levantes del suelo y
han sido muchas las ocasiones en mí en
mi carrera y en mi vida en las que he
tenido que enfrentar esos miedos la más
importante y es la que les quiero
compartir hoy fue en 1999 yo ya tenía
cuatro discos ya había probado el éxito
con una canción que se llama mis
impulsos sobre ti y el camino y más
fuerte de lo que pensaba pero luego vino
una caída muy fuerte en mi carrera saqué
un disco muy conceptual la gente no lo
entendió se vendieron tres copias me
dejaron de contratar para conciertos
esto no lo saben porque nunca lo anuncia
en la tv notas pero la pasé bastante mal
y en 1998 mi banda se desintegra me
dicen adiós esto no está funcionando mi
manager me
estuvimos con conflicto de demanda milan
a la había metido en una casa que quería
intentar comprar para tener un
patrimonio llegaron los huthis la
reestructuración financiera se caiga la
moneda de méxico y pierda todo mi dinero
estaba sin lana sin banda mi manager me
demandó y hay aparte le di el anillo de
compromiso a mi novia para ver si se
casara conmigo en mi hijo güey hasta que
no tenga estabilidad yo no le entro y
pomelo regreso y dije güey porque siento
mojado y voltea y había un perro me
estaba brindando la pierna no así
qué pedo entonces
yo pensé y dije way o sea este ya mejor
me dijo hacer tacos o para vender
garnachas y de repente llega mi hermano
que era como mi asesor no y éste me
había llamado una persona y me dijo oye
te gusta el cine quiero que hagas la
música instrumental para mi película es
mi ópera prima yo soy un tipo del teatro
nunca ha hecho cine pero creo que te va
a gustar el proyecto y yo creo que tú
eres el indicado y qué presupuesto hay
la neta no hay lana porque en ese
entonces no había suntracs el cine
mexicano los antros se habían quedado en
la época de pedro infante y jorge
negrete y todo eso y luego viene una
época de puras ficheras y el día de los
albañiles y así el cine mexicano y
entonces pues no había suntracs
mexicanos entonces no había un
antecedente de éxito y me dijo wei ahí
hay cuatro pesos para la orquesta
simpática
pues ahora le va mi hermano llegue a mi
segway qué estás haciendo
o sea por qué vas a hacer eso ponte a
hacer canciones para paulina rubio o
para thalía wave que te dejen una lana
eso no te va a dejar nada y estás todo
endeudado y estás y es y ahí fue
la palabra ay me cayó al 20 y dije pues
el va todas mi hermano le dije o
sea ya no tengo nada que perder y amo el
cine y me apasiona y voy a hacer algo
por mí porque me gusta a mí no me
importa si lo van a aplaudir no me
importa si va a ser va a vender muchos
discos o si nadie se va a dar cuenta que
lo hice luego hacer porque yo quiero
hacer fue una corazonada mi mente a lo
mejor decía no vayas jingles de una
refresquería o algo así para sacar lana
no te pongas a hacer música para si
estás loco pero la corazonada me dijo vi
por aquí
y me puse a hacer toda la música de la
película y al final llega el director de
escúcheme y se oye por qué no haces una
canción que igual la cante y alejandra
guzmán o que la cante julieta venegas o
alguien es una chava del equipo sí
y cuando me senté a hacer esta canción
como que salió todo el dolor todo el
miedo todo lo que traía lo logré poner
ahí lo logré poner en un papel
y decirle a la gente que quieres ver
grande me quieres ver grande a pesar de
lo débil que soy
porque dije pues pues muestra lo que
estás sintiendo lo importante es que tú
lo sientas ya no sabía que todo el mundo
se iba a enterar de eso no yo lo hice
pues porque me hacía mucho sentido con
la película y de repente lo que es el
destino no esté llega al director y me
dice no no me gustó mucho como la
cantaste y la quiero que la cantas tú y
de repente en ese momento a otra cosa
que se me olvidó platicar es que ya no
ya estaba yo con la carta de retiro de
la disquera donde yo estaba porque ya no
estaba vendiendo discos no me está yendo
nada bien y me dijeron no me 4 ahí está
tu carta de retiro entonces también ya
no estaba listo o sea ya no estaba en
una disquera y de repente recibí una
llamada y me dice un amigo de cual se me
hizo y arturo estaba en la secundaria
contigo ay me prestaba para los
pingüinos y el gansito así arturo cómo
estás campeón cómo te ha ido pues te
tengo una noticia soy el nuevo director
de tu disquera que aún no te voy a dejar
ir qué estás haciendo
pota le dije
una película bueno creo que ni te
interese no sé si me interesa ver déjame
verla y el wave fue se sentó conmigo a
ver la película oyó la música las
canciones y me gusta es un madrazo yo le
voy a dar todo el apoyo ni talquino
tropo creer en eso llega el director me
dice o porque no nos das ideas para la
promoción y de broma les dije pues que
el tráiler de la película en las salas
de cine y vídeo cantando la canción es
la verdad
si no les diría y si no sí sí sí es
viable
sí sí sí sí sí señor vamos a meterle la
edad ni hacemos que el vídeo salga en
las pantallas
y yo no lo podía creer cuando me senté
con con mis amigos hacía mejor que
fuimos a ver una película de nicholas
que he hecho no creo que la sala estaba
medio vacía y con catarata foxton y
century fox y un bombero inunda
y la radio no quería tocar la canción
que por qué decía sexo pero una palabra
altisonante no debe de salir en la radio
entonces la denunciaban como amor pudor
y lágrimas' e incluso radio centro le
ponía cuando no salían sexo pudor y
lágrimas de pudor y la
eran otras épocas porque ahorita te
pongo en cuatro patas
pero en aquel entonces o en aquel
entonces no pasaba
[Aplausos]
lo demás fue historia
un brandy lugar
digna
boomerang
te da
a veces pienso
no le mete al revés me siento más frío y
no estoy a veces me ausento de mis
sentimientos y luego sonrío
recuerdo y me aferro a vivir ya veces
quisiera matar por tu amor tan sólo por
un momento
y es que todavía
se encuentra
lo que me seria
acerté
mucho más
siento
llegarme por completo
[Música]
sexo pudo
lágrimas me da igual
miranda
pero verá si nunca
al volver a inundar la gomera
nunca
si quieres ver grande
a pesar de lo débil que soy y si toco
hasta el fondo me sacas de nuevo por eso
me quedo
me aferro y te quiero a morir'
por eso que adentro tú estás todo el
tiempo viviendo del sufrir
[Música]
y es que todavía no encuentro
lo que me sería normal
[Música]
para darte
mucho más lento
carmen
el completo sexo pudo
lágrimas
p
vuelvo a mentir honda
pero nada
a comer
y verán
[Música]
ah
como verán tiro de un gran tirón al
verano
en el mundo
de hecho pudo
y lágrimas me da igual
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias nunca tengan miedo
la que la mente ambiente nunca tengan
miedo sus peores terrores cuando el 90%
no se cumple ni el 10% cuando se cumplen
resulta que somos más fuertes de lo que
pensábamos y logramos salir adelante y
eso nos hace mejores personas y de eso
venimos a la vida a vivir solo por hoy
ya vivir para seguir creciendo y seguir
aprendiendo todos los días así que no
tengan nunca miedo y lo que les les haga
que su corazón lata ese es el camino
correcto eso es lo que ustedes quieren
conseguir vayan por sus sueños nunca
dejen de de luchar por eso gracias que
que les vaya muy bien mucho éxito
[Música]